تبدو حماس صارمه في موقفها فيما يتعلق باي
مفاوضات الى اي مدى تعتقد بان اسرائيل
ستقبل في النهايه بشروط
حماس الامر كله يتوقف على حجم الضغط الذي
يشعر به الاسون في هذا الوقت
خاصه فيما اتصل بعائلات المحتجزين
والمختطفين في غزه واعتقد ان هذه هي
الطريقه الوحيده التي يمكن من خلالها قياس
الضغطات طبعا المختطفون يريدون العوده
والعائله تضغط بشكل كبير وهذا هو ما يحدد
موازين القوى على الارض في تقديري هناك
متبعه عن كتب لما ستحمله قادمه ايام
نتنياهو الان الذي خسر الكثير من شعبيته
في الاونه الاخيره بالنظر الى الاختلالات
الامنيه التي مكنت حماس من القيام بهجومها
في السابع اكتوبر الى
جانب تراجع شعبيته بسبب مجموعه من
السياسات الاخرى والضغط الذي يعاني منه من
الداخل ايضا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تضغط من جانبها على اسرائيل من من اجل
التقليل من القصف المستمر لغزه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الان تخسر الكثير من
شعبيتها وهي تحت ضغط امريكي داخلي ايضا
لنفهم اكثر من له مصلحه اكبر في الدخول في
مفاوضات
وتهدئه تقول بعض المصادر الانسانيه
الاسرائيليه بانها قد تمتد بين اسبوعين
وحتى الشهر كاقصى تقدير هل هي اسرائيل ام
الولايات
[موسيقى]
المتحده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
الواقع لم تكن اكثر عزله في الساحه
الدوليه مما هي عليه اليوم نتذكر ما كان
في السابق مع نكسون في فيتنام ورجن ورؤساء
اخرين واجهوا الكثير من الازمات الان
بايدن يواجه عزله دوليه كبيره غير
مسبوقه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
التي
عرقلت تمرير قرار اممي لوقف اطلاق النار
او وقف الاعمال العدائيه باستخدام حق
الفيتو اذا هناك ضغط متزايد على اداره
بايدن
و الاداره الامريكيه الان مطالبه بالقيام
بجهد من اجل وقف العنف بالنسبه لنتنياهو
فهو لا يكترث على الاطلاق بالحرب الدائره
على في غزه لانه مستفيد من هذه الحرب لانه
كلما استمرت الحرب وامتدت الحرب لفتره
طويله كلما تاجلت
الانتخابات ايضا من الهامه ان نشير ان
اغلبيه
ال المحتجزين او المختطفين
هم ايضا مناوئون لنتنياهو اذا اعتقد ان
هذا يشكل ضغط متزايد على نتنياهو طيب
تحدثت
عن عزله امريكيه تعيشها جراء
موقفها تجاه اسرائيل وحربها التي تشنها
على غزه هناك اجتما
لمجلس الامن الدولي يتعلق بتوسيع نطاق
المساعدات الى غزه وقد تم تاجيله الى
اليوم الخميس تقول المصادر بناء على طلب
امريكي ما مصير
الاجتماع اذا تم خلال الساعات
المقبله من الصعب جدا نتوقع الذي سيحدث في
هذا الاجتماع لكن اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تحاول ان تقنع الاطراف
ذات السلا باستخدام لغه او لهجه تكون
خفيفه ضد اسرائيل والولا المتحده
الامريكيه قد تستخدم الفيتو مره اخرى
امريكا استخدمت الفيتو
86 مره على مدى السنوات الكثير الماضيه
ومعظم هذه المرات كانت طبعا دائما واعتقد
ان حق الفيتو يعرقل تمرير الكثير من
القرارات المهمه وينبغي القول بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي الوحيده
التي استخدمت حق الفيتو لعرقله تمرير هذا
القرار
اذا موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يبقى
صعبا شكرا جزيلا لك ستيفان زونس استاذ
الامن الدولي والسياسه الخارجيه في جامعه
سان
فرانسيسكو